so going back who exactly was eduardo
so eduardo saverin um you know was
was uh basically in the rooming group
with zuckerberg he was his friend
eduardo came from a wealthy brazilian
family
and actually come to america and his
family moved to miami because of
kidnapping threats
down in brazil they kidnapped rich kids
um
and so his family had moved him there so
he had some money
and so when uh when you know him and him
and mark were both very socially awkward
geeky guys
spend any amount of time with those guys
i promise you those are socially awkward
geeky guys
it's not hard to see um eduardo uh
you know became a member of a finals
club he had
wealth and connections so he made it
into the phoenix club
uh mark couldn't get into the phoenix
club which is one of those old
you know those those fraternities
basically their final steps they go back
hundreds of years
um and they're basically the social life
at harvard although that's changed since
then but
anyways uh mark got upset went out got
drunk one night
um and uh and and and made this website
face mash where you could vote on who
the hottest girl at harvard was you know
he hacked into computer servers he
pulled up pictures of all these girls
and and it leaked out all over the
all over the college campus uh got him
in huge trouble he almost got kicked out
of school
wasn't he comparing pictures of girls to
farm animals
yeah so in his blog which he kept along
with the
thing and we have his blog so we know
what he was doing he was writing uh
you know we should compare them to farm
animals all this kind of stuff and
and even when he got in trouble you know
his argument was well the girls were
beating the farm animals
so he shouldn't be mad he doesn't really
understand or at the time did not
understand
why it was such a bad thing to be doing
um but
he caught the attention of the
winklevoss twins because they were
working on their own website the
harvardconnection.com
which was kind of a dating website with
some social
interaction in it and so it had some of
the things that did end up
i think in facebook but it was more
oriented towards dating and socializing
um but they hired mark they wanted
someone to work for them who knew
computers
he was in the newspaper for almost
getting in trouble for a computer
program that went viral
so he went to work for them blew them
off and went to eduardo so eduardo had
some money and mark went to eduardo and
said i've got an idea for a website
people will put their own pictures up so
we won't get in trouble
um if you put up the money you can be
the cfo
and you can have thirty percent and so
eduardo put up a thousand dollars which
ends up being the greatest investment in
the history of the world
um because it turns into five billion
dollars but anyways
he puts up the money and mark writes the
code for
for the facebook and and basically uh
it launches all over harvard it spreads
it spreads it spreads and and and it was
just huge
and the winklevoss twins you know
realize that they're
cut out that they're not involved that
mark had been lying to them and leading
them on
so they sued him and eduardo you know
eventually
what happens is when facebook starts to
take off
uh mark moves to california meets up
with sean parker
and shawn was like the cool kid of
silicon valley
uh sean had started napster when he was
in high school
um which you know ended up getting sued
out of existence right
and then he was the he founded something
called plaxo
um which he got fired from when he was
caught with cocaine
and then he became the first president
of harvard until he got caught with
cocaine so
allegedly i guess but anyways uh sean is
a wild guy
fascinating um a genius a true genius i
think
uh but eduardo did not like sean did not
want sean to be involved
and when mark and sean got together they
essentially cut eduardo out
um they left he stayed behind in boston
to finish college
um he got so upset that he froze all the
bank accounts
of facebook at the time which was all
his money at the time it was 18 grand
when he froze the accounts
so they went to peter thiel and that's
when peter thiel invested
a half a million dollars but said who is
this guy listed as your cfo
he's not even in california he's not
part of facebook
so they cut eduardo out so eduardo ended
up suing as well and that's where i came
into the picture
that's when they settled for five
billion dollars and he moved away
yeah it's worth nine billion now he's
living in singapore well he came back
for
covet i don't know where he is right now
but yes i have not
not seen or heard from him since so if
anyone out there
give eduardo a call and then you can
send me a little gift basket be very
nice
yeah that movie was beautifully shot the
cinematography in that movie was amazing
all on
super tight lenses super low light
like it was just a beautiful movie um
were you involved in that in the
shooting of that at all yeah so i was on
set
uh for a lot of it i would say that
wasn't a fun
set um it was not a party uh david
fincher
you know scott rudin who was a producer
aaron sorkin and kevin spacey
who was a producer as well it was a very
big personalities
um on a very dark kind of intense
set and david fincher is absolutely
incredible
um and that movie shot for shot is
beautiful
but the way he does things is very
intense um i remember one scene
where like a busload of girls pulls up
to a finals club and these girls get out
of the bus
and that's all the scene is it's like a
five seconds of scene
and he shot it from 7 p.m to 7 a.m
just over and over and over again for 12
hours
and like i don't even know what he's
looking for i don't know what it is he's
seeing
but when it's on screen it's it's
perfect but he really
i mean that's how he shoots a movie so
it was really intense
um but i was there yeah it was it was
wild it was incredible
and i remember you know the first time
you read the script it was like wow
that's an
amazing script and then the first time
you sit in the movie and the movie opens
and it's a conversation and it goes on
for 10 minutes
and it's brilliant it's intense and it's
incredible as you say it's dark and you
wouldn't expect a movie about facebook
to be that um i remember when they came
to me with the title they were like
we're going to call it the social
network and i was like that doesn't sell
me a good title
i mean it doesn't even say anything but
now when you watch the movie it's
actually a perfect title because the
idea was
it wasn't really about facebook it was
something much bigger than that
and it was really a character study
between mark and all of these other
people
um and also about this massive change in
all of our lives
with dark undertones um and i feel like
what's happened since then
has only made that movie more and more
true you know mark has become more and
more
the character from the social network
and facebook has become more and more
what he created then um and so i feel
like fincher
and sorkin really captured something um
very true that you know 10 years later
um
feels very real to me yeah it's creepy
how accurate that turned out huh
yeah i mean it's you know mark
everything mark's done since then you
can see the underpinnings of
you know how he dealt with his friends
and how he dealt with people
who were involved with the project or
you know and what his goal
is all the time and sort of this kind of
darkness
in a way that hopefully um will slowly
recede
yeah a lot of people think he's an alien
i mean i don't think he's an alien i
think he's a genius for absolutely
brilliant guy
but i do think he thinks of the world
differently than we do
i think he really really thinks if we
were all on facebook all the time
sharing everything with no walls between
us it would be a better world
and that if data were free if we were
living in this facebook village
um um you know but at the same time
there's
a little bit of of control issues you
know
he knows that he's right and everyone
else is wrong
and whenever facebook does something and
everyone is angry about it
he wades through it um and then in the
end we all give up so
maybe he is right but uh but you know
over and over again they've done things
to upset people
and just push through um and that i
think that speaks to mark's character is
that he he believes what he's doing is
correct
and that's why he's retained total
control and uh
and and that you know even when it's
pointed out that what he's doing may not
be correct for everyone he he sticks
with it um
until he really really needs so i i
don't know how much better anything will
ever get
in that world so how did you eventually
come to meet the winkle winklevi
yeah so i reached out after eduardo came
to me and i was looking for sources i
found them on facebook i
had seen an article somewhere that they
were suing um but i didn't really know
much about
why or what was really going on um so i
reached out and i met with them
in new york and uh you know they're they
walk into the room and it's like
something out of greek mythology you
know it doesn't look real they look like
they were invented on a hollywood set
because you know they're six foot five
identical twin olympic rowers
um they they at the time they were still
in training
so they ate the same they worked out the
same they were the same
um and they're they're physically
intimidating guys
and they come from a privileged
background of the men's wealth
and uh you know that sort of thing um
so you immediately think they've got to
be the bad guys in the story um because
you know i grew up in the 80s and every
80s movie
they were the bad guys you know they
were the ones dressed up in skeleton
costumes chasing the karate kid around
the gym
um and so immediately you think mark's
the good guy and they're the bad guys
but you kind of know mark's not the good
guy because you also know
how people have reacted to him how he's
dealt with people around him
there's this kind of angry nerd thing
going on there
and so it was a nuanced story but but
originally when i met the winklevoss
twins
i was definitely in awe of them um just
because of
of what you know who they were but they
were the guys who were suing mark for
stealing their idea
and that's all they were at that time
they were angry very angry
they had even though they had settled
this mark they wanted to throw out the
settlement
because it was never about money for
them they didn't care about money
um that's one of the cool things about
the whole social network story
nobody cared about money in that story
mark never cared about money money was
meaningless to him
he became one of the richest man in the
world but never cared about money when
he was in high school he came up with an
idea
microsoft had offered him a million
dollars for it and he turned it down
because he didn't care he said i'll give
it away for free and that's the guy who
created
you know facebook uh eduardo didn't
really care about making money because
he came from a wealthy family
he just wanted to prove something to his
family um the winklevoss twins didn't
care about making money because they
came from a wealthy family
only sean parker really cared about
making money um so that's kind of cool
about that story but anyways the
winklevoss twins was kind of like
he was kind of like the snake oil
salesman of the whole of the story right
well that's how eduardo described him i
mean water did not like sean
really thought he was just trying to
sell something um and sean
you know justin timberlake captured the
character perfectly
and i think sean became more and more
like justin timberlake
after the movie came out
i